all we can do is our best
and sometimes the best that we can do
is to start over it's one of the most
highly anticipated movies
of all time where did that bring you
back to me as moviegoers saw in the last
installment
the avengers are facing the highest
stakes they've ever seen why'd you do
that
we're in the end game now we sat down
with the core 6 to see if end game
lives up to the hype so this movie is
under lock and key
how many of you raise your hands if
you've seen it none of you have seen it
do you know what happens outside of this
in your personal scenes
we're i was only given my little section
i find it strange that you haven't been
able to watch your own movie
but why is it is it because mark can't
be trusted is it because
the rest of you can't believe why does
everyone say that
if any one of us asked i'm sure we
probably could i just think
personally i'm actually going to try and
enjoy the experience at the premiere
three hours long our finest hours yeah i
think definitely bring a bag lunch i'm
hoping there's a
lawrence of arabia musical intermission
as well because those are always fun
is there going to be an intermission
three hours that's almost unprecedented
mark suggested you wear a diaper then
you said that there we go okay
bring a clean box of kleenex and a
diaper box of cleaning
and a diaper there was an emotional post
on social media
and it appeared that you were saying
goodbye to your character what should we
read into that
it is the end of a 22 21
movie tapestry a 10-year process this
has been
an enormous part of my life it will
follow me for until the day i die
and that's that's really when you think
about it it's easy to get emotional
about it and and i you know you try to
prepare yourself for the completion and
and then the day came and it just
it was more than i thought it was going
to be and i was really really beside
myself and
just you know i know you and i talked
about it and it just it was just uh
it got me i'm an emotional guy most of
you have kids has this
upped the cool factor uh i was just
telling the guys one of my kids thinks
that i'm cool just one yeah just one and
he gets fed the most he gets looked
after
[Laughter]
the other one's like wonder woman so
they sleep outside
who spends the most time in hair and
makeup i think
lady hemsworth
and she's so pretty can you guys give me
one word to describe the end
to the movie satisfying satisfying i
think a lot of times look it's another
customer who has not yet uh seen the
product in any you know
it's like when you want to like tv shows
when you have the final finale how many
times do they stick the landing how many
times do you walk away saying
i exactly wanted that to go the way i
wanted it to go
this movie will really i think they
deliver i think they really do stick the
landing in term of in terms of
you know addressing the arcs and and
really finding a
completion yeah nailed it
hey everybody it's charlie there's brand
new avengers footage we have to break
down there was also a big press
conference yesterday where chris evans
said even more
before the russos cut him off so i'll
play that clip in a second just talking
about the ending of a big arc he made it
sound like he was getting dangerously
close to revealing big spoilers about
captain america's story so the russo
started buzzing him just to get him to
start talking about something else and
they started talking about scott pilgrim
and having an argument over paul rudd's
birthday there's a new round of the imax
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave an
avengers comment on the video
this is that funny clip of chris evans
talking about the end of captain america
well i guess i i can give i could get
broad strokes i i think just
the the completion of of the arc but
that's not safe to say right that this
movie does kind of provide
kind of a uh an ending to a lot of
judges
it's so funny to watch the russos just
buzz him like nope you can't say
anything about this movie even though
this is the international press
conference and we're supposed to be
talking about this movie
that's what the russo said in the clip
that i posted this past weekend where
they're like we cannot wait to not
talk about this movie with you because
they're trying to not talk about it as
much as possible
but the actual footage that they show
here is just part of the clips that they
showed off this past weekend to press
that i was talking about i've already
broken down a lot of this is them
arguing about going to get thanos and
captain marvel saying
why don't we just go get the stones from
thanos kill him
and use the stones again to bring
everyone back it's one of the very early
scenes in the movie and obviously
because it's happening so early and
they're saying that yeah our plan is
going to be so easy we'll do it right
away
means that it's not going to be
successful what you do not see during
this clip is that it comes after nebula
gives them a bunch of information so
that means that iron man and nebula have
already made it back
that was the other clip that they showed
off this weekend i broke that down i'll
link that video at the end of this where
i explain what happens during that
but as you can see war machine is the
one who sort of balks at captain
america's plan like what
what the hell are you talking about
where have you been this whole time
and why is it that you think that you're
so hot standing in a room with a bunch
of avengers
who tried to do just what you're talking
about we tried to take the gauntlet from
him before and it did not work her
rationale is is that she was out
protecting other planets in cree scroll
space
they sort of explained that at the end
of the captain marvel movie where she
tells yon raw
go back tell the supreme intelligence
that i'm coming to end your war
end all the lies so presumably she's
been there for the last 20 years trying
to police that part of the galaxy
whole lot of untold backstory there so
they'll probably address it with a
couple lines of dialogue that captain
marvel gets during this movie
but also during the captain marvel
sequel eventually in a couple years
whenever that ends up coming
funny enough nobody in any version of
the scenes that they've shown this off
there's a five minute version they
showed off the other day
where nobody corrects him after this and
says language
just because it's meant to be a very
serious badass moment they climb onto
the back of the guardianship the benatar
and they strap in rocket then gets a
funny moment where he says who here has
not been into space captain america
black widow
war machine raised their hand and rocket
says you better not throw up on my ship
so there are a couple funny moments and
you can say that that thor moment where
he summons his hammer
just to sort of test captain marvel a
little bit is kind of meant to be funny
the other new thing that we learned from
the avengers endgame press conference
the other day too
is that this is the first time that brie
larson ever played captain marvel she
shot
these scenes for avengers end game
before she did the captain marvel movie
so it'll be interesting to see what her
take on a fully fledged fully developed
captain marvel is like
compared to the proto version of the
character that we saw during the captain
marvel movie where she's slowly becoming
captain marvel by the end of the film
the other really important thing to note
about her too is that at no point during
the captain marvel movie does anyone
call her captain marvel
so i think that they give her that name
during avengers end game at some point
and it has something to do with captain
america
inspiring her to take that name and if
you haven't read any of those captain
marvel comic book stories it was
actually captain america
in the comics that told her to take the
captain marvel name
because originally it belonged to marvel
the male version of the character
the other really important thing that
you don't get from this scene is that
they're going to the farm the garden
where thanos is at the end of avengers
infinity war that's where nebula tells
them to go
but bruce banner is not kidding when he
says that they go in
short-handed because iron man is not
there and you notice
that the hulk is not here either boehner
isn't on the back of this jet because
as of this moment early in avengers end
game he still
has not come to an agreement with the
hulk so he can't hook out yet
that's why we're all theorizing that the
first time that he actually goes back
into hulk form is when thanos comes to
destroy the avengers facility in all the
rubble here
there was actually a toy recently that
shows him ripping a couple beams apart
in that special spandex purple suit so
people are like well maybe banner just
gets caught in the explosion with the
other avengers like you see ant-man
really tiny jumping around all these
giant office supplies so he
gets caught in the explosion too you
only see three of these avengers
actually fighting thanos outside in the
rubble though but it just lets you know
that they're going to be a couple
attempts
at a fight with thanos this looks like
it's going to be slightly more
successful than the last one because
they have more of the avengers there
together
there's also a rumor that one of thanos
counter measures for the avengers early
in the film because they say why don't
we just take the gauntlet from him
and try to bring everyone back with the
stones really simple
is that in order to prevent the avengers
from doing that thanos himself
really early in the film tries to
destroy the infinity gauntlet himself to
prevent them from rolling his changes
back
so if that happens really early in the
film that gives you an idea for how they
have to try some other way come up with
some special plan for fixing everything
that involves the quantum realm the
quantum suits all that stuff that comes
later but as all the avengers say during
this good morning america clip is that
none of them have seen the entire film
but they all joke about chris evans when
he talks about the ending being the
satisfying ending that you don't really
get from a lot of tv shows i know we're
getting ready for game of thrones to
premiere so we're all talking about
whether or not the ending of that is
going to be satisfying to the fans
he claims that the end of avengers end
game is exactly what fans will want
which i think is a tall order but i'm
willing to give them the benefit of the
doubt now
no matter how amazing it is they're
always going to be a couple people that
are pissed off about the ending
he does say that it's a very satisfying
end to
captain america's ark in this arc of
films but the really important thing to
remember is
the russos put a lot of doctored footage
in these clips so that might not be
exactly like this during the final
version of the movie in fact they've
already revealed that in the last
trailer that we saw with captain america
and iron man in the alleyway where he
says do you trust me and captain america
says yes then they seemingly shake hands
because it's supposed to be captain
america's hand and his outfit there
they say that that scene is not actually
in the movie well
we're in a tasty moment but we can't go
into too much detail actually isn't in
the movie
so you know that we tell people that we
uh manipulate
trailers in order to obfuscate what
happens in these fields
what does that then mean about the
actual version of events that happen in
that it
probably goes down with either a
different character or it might have
something to do with captain america
wearing his
outfit from the original avengers movie
and them wanting to hide that or because
ant-man is there for a lot of that too
ant-man could be the person in this
scene and they could have just changed
the arm
in post-production to make it look like
it's captain america shaking his hand
and not
ant-man because they're taking over
jimmy kimmel almost
every single night this week we might
get more footage either later tonight or
later this week whatever ends up
dropping i'll do videos for it
but while we're all watching this just
remember that some of the scenes might
be doctored so that certain characters
don't look the way that they look in the
actual version of the movie or certain
characters are digitally removed
that's part of the fun about big
avengers movies like this just imagine
what it's going to be like when we get
to avengers 5 in a couple more years
it is really fun to watch all the other
actors making fun of mark ruffalo and
chris hemsworth
chris hemsworth because he spends more
time in the makeup chair than black
widow
and making fun of mark ruffalo for
giving away spoilers too much
there's a really cool thing that just
happened the rock just explained what's
going on with the black adam movie
that's going to be happening next year
so i'll post that video of him talking
about it
while you wait for everything click here
for my breakdown of that other 10
minutes worth of footage they showed off
to the press yesterday
and click here for all my game of
thrones season 8 death predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight